hi guys serve right again and today I am
going to I have no idea what I'm going
to do well basically last time I
finished this and what the actual [ __ ]
is this seriously what the hell going to
fix that later on now
I had something in mind but I'm not
entirely sure of this I might even make
a wooden roller coaster on the other
side of the river because if I look at
this right now I would say this is this
part of the park is pretty much finished
we've got the Main Street going we've
got the icarus area going with stuff now
this area does lack flat rights I may
place another flat right here and here
stuff like that and maybe a flat right
here I'm going to do that later on and
maybe something in here if I have enough
space for that and of course Polly is
wrong
going to do foliage in the last stage
and maybe not even on camera because
it's going to create such Mac massive
amount of like I can't deal with that
but now I think I'm just going to go
ahead and make a randomly old wooden
roller coaster over here because PEP add
on just the second PEP add on actually
came out recently and it had a wooden
coaster CT so now everybody in the
community is all happy and they're all
trying stuff with the CT and I'm not one
of those guys who has joined in the fun
yet and I feel like I should try it so
I've got this cool little where the hell
is it word on CT from Europa Park and
I'm going to see if I can do anything
with it so
okay so they'll be it for today I had
the idea that this area of the park
would kind of be the farmers area slash
Germans area so that's why I chose for
they for the German ich temple thing for
the station building but it still looks
a little bit weird and I really need to
add some details to it and stuff so that
that's what I'm going to do next time so
till then